how do the things we use every day like
ads phones and even medical devices go
from idea to finished products it's with
the guidance of a product manager one of
the most highly coveted roles in
technology product managers function as
the CEO of a product effectively leading
their own startup within a company while
working cross-functionally with a
variety of teams in udacity's product
manager nanodegree program you'll Define
product strategy design and test a
prototype create test plans get early
feedback effectively prioritize issues
run a go no go launch meeting and create
a comprehensive go to market plan all
with instructors from Google you won't
just learn how to be a product manager
you will get hands-on experience making
real life product decisions with a
project from crafting your own product
pitch to managing product development
while identifying and mitigating risk to
communicating with a variety of
different stakeholders and delivering a
product to Market giving you the skills
to be an in-demand product manager own
the decision about what gets built but
also influence every aspect of how it
gets built and launched by becoming a
product manager enroll in udacity's
product manager nanodegree program today
[Music]